so actually I remember very much the
first time I heard of you was about a
year ago or so when gamergate was just
starting to percolate up and I tweeted
out I said I want to do something about
gamergate can you guys point me in the
right direction because I really could
not get a hold of it which it seems like
no one still can get a hold no one can
explain but but your name came up and
Miley innopolis and Adam Baldwin and a
couple other people popped up and I was
looking around and I did one video on it
and I basically said I tried to lay it
out but I basically don't know what's
going on here right now since then I've
had Milo on and I thought he did a
pretty good explanation you become sort
of a I guess like a heroine of the
gamergate movement for a lot of the
reasons you're discussing here so if you
were going to explain it in like two
minutes how would you explain the thing
that is gamergate well just the first
thing to know I am NOT a gamer yeah and
in fact I've looked at some of the games
that are caught and they'd you know
there's too much violence and mayhem and
it's I mean but I also don't like shows
like breaking bad or I can't watch them
too much violence oh you believe they
existed but of course it's not my taste
I do prefer you know Pride and Prejudice
or you know at the latest PBS Downton
Abbey that sort of thing yeah uh but
it's not
I don't impose that on everyone and I
recognize there can be great movies
Alfred Hitchcock was a great director
but I will never see psycho I'm too
afraid it's not my I can't I don't enjoy
the experience of being terrified in the
theater that people do they and it's
there's it's harmless and so when the
video game controversy erupted
I took I took a measure of it I I saw
some familiar players because I'd been
in some of these same battles and I saw
that some of the feminist critics were
cherry-picking they were misrepresenting
and uh and that the gamergate was being
judged by there are some extreme people
associated with it at the periphery but
then like everything but like every what
movement I mean Occupy Wall Street there
were crazy people on the periphery sure
and and black lives matter if you go to
the periphery but you
what you should do is go to the center
and what are they saying that's what I
tried to do is go and see what they were
saying yeah and these these critics
first you had critics that said video
games are causing mayhem they create
violence no one has been able to show
that psychologists are already just
tired of it they're not needed to forget
it you're not there's it's just going in
a circle no one has been able to show it
yeah and hasn't there been some studies
that have proven it actually does the
reverse because we get some of the
regression out yeah instead of actually
shooting someone and it takes a lot I
mean no one knows what creates a you
know a sociopathic criminal but it's
probably not videogames yeah
and but and in previous generations they
thought it was comic books who had a
corrupting influence on the morals of
the young or it was television and any
new medium goes through this and games
seemed to be there and then there was
the feminist critics and they were
saying it was causing the well they were
saying two things but the games
themselves are sexist and they they
create attitudes of you know sexist and
I I just did not see evidence of that I
did see that some of them had sexy women
and but if the players liked it and many
of them you know men are known to like
images of sexy women I just didn't
understand why we were demonizing that
and people say well feminists will say
that that the male gaze looking at
women's bodies objectifying which
feminists I was a part of a group of
pro-sex feminist or libertarian
feminists who it was live and let live I
mean I I'm not against people there was
a whole group of feminists that were
against having you know women posing in
Playboy or or the Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue and all of that Catherine
MacKinnon Andrea Dworkin but there was a
whole group of us that were opposed and
I think we won the argument but
apparently they won the assistant
professor ships they've been there ever
since it teaching these might have won
the battle they might have won the war
teaching them we want all the battles
when they were the first so-called
culture war we won the arguments we had
the New York Times on our side we had
new you
the media and now they've been they've
been laboring away you know with their
theories and then a relentless and now
they have the backing of the Department
of Education because through so in the
educational system they can make a
federal case of everything so it's
difficult I know I think in the end we
will prevail because I have great faith
and just human ability to see through
nonsense eventually it has to fall right
so my question there was what is
gamergate and I think your answer
because your answer I had almost nothing
to do with gamergate I think it was the
right answer right because that seems to
be the confusion about what is gamergate
nobody seems to really understand what
it is I think at this point it's morphed
into so many different things but at the
core it was a group of gamers who were
there were issues I don't understand is
not a gamer they were irritated by some
cronyism in the right that some of the
magazines were being paid off by the
manufacturer all that was going on and
that that happened we saw that in radio
when it was a younger medium there was
Paola has to be sorted out I think
gaming had to go through that maybe it
still has to but it's it's improved
since gamergate that's for sure
but then they also would find themselves
in you know getting attacked by game
critics or games evaluated because they
objectified women or something and and
they were just thinking we just want to
play our games yeah you know we don't
really yeah so whatever and and then
they had these critiques of the games
that were so cherry picked and these
gamers they know their games don't mess
with that and they know the games and
then so they were this is of course
Anita sarkeesian and her videos it was
infuriating these are some young guys
mainland some girls and they see their
games being misrepresented or she'll
pick a scene out make it look like one
thing was totally different or take a
video no one ever watched that had you
know a following of five and and act as
though it's typical of the game so they
knew it was cheating they knew and they
got really mad now what I liked about
many of them is they they fought back
with arguments their videos they were it
was it was this explosion of
communication now there were crazy
opportunists at the edges or maybe they
weren't even part of gamergate maybe it
no one knows who sent threats right and
people on both sides of the controversy
get them yeah so that's the interesting
part that there was this group of its
younger people playing video games they
felt that the system that they you know
they loved these games they felt that
the man you know the video game
manufacturers they're buying the reviews
and all that it starts with that but I
think you just hit it that it became
this thing where suddenly this group of
people who have nothing in common we
they don't know what each other's skin
color is or sexuality is or any of this
stuff is but they all found this common
thing related to authoritarianism and
they fought it and that's why I was
fascinated and they thought and they
thought and they they you know it just
for its it may erupt again Iike it goes
it comes and goes but there was
comradery and to two times maybe you
know two times we've had these gamergate
hookups where because you only know each
it's just a hashtag it's an organization
and in both DC and in in London we had a
meet up and I met the gamers that and
they were there you can't beat a more
delightful friendly group of people so
that should that be the piece that gives
you the hope that you were alluding to a
second ago that there was this group of
younger people that said we're not going
to take this [ __ ] and if they're not
going to take it they were they were you
know they were it was majority guys but
lots of fantastic young women and again
these are yes it's hardcore gamers I
don't know maybe 70 or 80 percent male
but there's some that are they're
fantastic and they were part of that
group so they even whatever they were
they could there are gay women and and
and every race I mean is it is
represented and you realize gamergate
was a consumer uprising really from
across the world across racial and class
and gender lines and it was just
defending a hobby they love right so
that's sort of what it is is that that's
why the regressive left really hated oh
yeah any of this right and they they
wanted to get the idea that there would
be a rebellion how dare you you do not
talk back to big sister right which is
so fascinating because because it was a
cross-section of people
they couldn't figure out who to guilt
into hating who more and that I think
transcends so many things that we now
see on college campuses and we see in
our public discourse in free speech and
all that for you personally how does it
feel as you just said you don't you were
never a gamer but but yet you're based
mom for these people how does it feel to
be part of something that you actually
unlike feminism where you had a vested
interest as a woman let's say now you're
part of something that you not only say
you don't care about it because you care
about these people obviously but as you
said you're not a gamer but you're a
leader in this thing it's happened
before I once came to the defense of
wrestlers because they were you know
their sport has been demolished by it
completely unnecessary interpretations
of this title nine equity law and so I
made friends with a lot of wrestlers and
I've never wrestled and I've never even
haven't ever even seen it I don't think
except you know accidentally channel
surfing right but I love these these are
just great guys and they oh but they
were and they couldn't you know they
they didn't have a voice in this debate
and these you know gender experts speak
for as if they're speaking for all women
or all of the left or something they
speak for themselves people should know
that yeah so how did it feel uh it it's
fine it's I mean because just cuz
everyone seems great and I I just I mean
they're as I said I haven't I can't
think of a group of people that were
just more diverse more welcoming good
sense of humor and creative I think you
know if I were to based on my knowledge
of gamers over the last year or so it's
someone's like obsessively gaming its
predictive of being an artist or an
engineer they're smart too yeah hard to
play these games yeah I mean we've got
the the army in the Navy now playing
video games to learn how to actually do
things so it's not that these you know I
was used to I was running around his
Mario eat mushrooms how about that did
for me not so much rooms in college but
what about online harassment because
that is also a piece of this and it also
fits the the feminism thing how much of
it is I don't say how much of it is real
there's obviously plenty of it's real
and we can look on any
YouTube's comment section and there's
everybody her asking everybody for every
other reason
right now it's Ellis how much concern
should we actually have for this or is
it something that is not that important
because it's just yeah we should have
concern for us just a certain category
of harassment first of all we have to
make distinctions if you're online and
you know they're different people can
disagree with you that could upset you
but you know little yeah yeah
and people can insult you that's life
just unfollow them yeah
then people can be obscene and you know
like it's probably more upsetting to a
woman than a man that kind of like
sexual and then they can issue like
really scary threats right obviously
with the really scary threats and
probably is the obscenity well let's
start with the threats there you have to
we have to do something about that and I
think we are I mean I think they get
reported and and when if they're
credible but the thing is with gamergate
and has anybody been hurt is there any
evidence of its its stall internet
nonsense I mean these that there are
these threatening mails and making even
where are they I mean where who has been
hurt exactly I mean the worst thing I
one of the worst things I read about was
my low getting terrible things in the
mail right I'll owe you an OP Allah so
well they were bad guys were their bomb
threats call yes only that he did yes
when we did our gamer meetup we met the
gamers in Washington DC a critic of
gamergate sent first of all he sent
completely rambling frightening notes to
the bar owner telling him not to host us
hmm
and it was very touching cuz his bar
owner was talking to me he was worried
you need thought what he cuz if this
critic made it sound like like he was
hosting some you know I don't know some
Nazis or something and the the bar owner
said what can I do this is America he
was he was from Afghanistan I think
we're in a minute immigrant right or
maybe Iraq he said what can I do this is
America and he I said are you gonna keep
us out he said no and then I they were
so pleased because in ever
he was very generous because that we
felt bad that they got a bomb threat and
the the imagine making a bomb threat in
DC they brought in vans and police dogs
but course being gamers we went outside
they partied outside yeah all right so
it had it had a nice ending and I
suppose that's all that we can do is
just you just keep going and you just
keep telling the truth and all that
which sort of gets me to my last
question which is I've been trying to
end all these interviews on the hope
part of all where do we go from here
with all the things we've been talking
about and I think you were in a piece
that I owe that Milo is also in about
the rise of the cultural libertarians
that there is this group of people now
that cut across the political spectrum
that include Bill Maher and Chris Rock
and people on the right like Milo and
people on the left that have realized we
got to get out of people's personal
lives we got to stop other in everybody
we got to stop judging everybody based
on color and sex and religion and all
that firm believer that this is the next
political movement in this country it
has to so I guess are you with me and
give me something else totally with you
and I think that it was my acquaintance
with the gamers that gave me that hope
because politically they're all over the
spectrum but they are very libertarian
for sure yeah and this was their how
they were acting and I just thought that
I got some insight into how they were
and to because they're younger I mean
the gamers are a lot a lot younger than
me most of them and that gives me hope
and and I what I like about it too is it
can unite us from people who are
concerned I'm still a registered
Democrat but out of respect for my
mother and father who are so liberal
I wouldn't dare her edges to anything
else but they but you can be
conservative you can be liberal what
unites us as Americans maybe is isn't
yeah in Westerners too it is a love of
freedom yeah I mean that's our so I
think it can bring people together and
we've right now it's not it's it's sort
of the bullies have the upper hand
yeah and so it's going to be a battle to
take the power away from them and
to where it belongs people who just who
are nice respectful and and who want of
other people and and realize other
people have different opinions and that
that's okay
and not to be policing I don't want
these authoritarians here who said they
could make the rules your arguments for
censorship and and doing away with due
process they're not going to work
they've been tried before with that with
unhappy results so read some history but
having said that I do think any crazy
things happening on campus right now
it's maybe a good thing yeah if people
are seeing it and will not be so easy so
ready to jump on yeah that I to me
that's the hope that I've been trying to
take for the last few weeks that even
even in cable news which is so endlessly
dumb and pandering that I was noticing
people were starting to say you know
where they'll cry racism every two
seconds in sexism and homophobia for the
first time they were kind of coming
around and being like this might be a
bit much so that's got to be that yeah
that's a good sign that's a good time
well what would you say just the average
person that not someone that's in the
public sphere but the average person
that wants to do something about this in
their in their well I would suggest that
you be somewhat skeptical not get too
carried away with a cause until you
check the facts now if you've got good
information and moral energy that's
moral progress that's Martin Luther King
that's civil rights
if you have bad information and moral
fervor that's fanaticism and history is
one long lesson in the dangers of
combining misinformation and moral
fervor so be careful choose your causes
carefully and if you're if you do that I
think it'll you know that that leads to
progress yeah being careful about your
causes and right now if you are a woman
and you are part of campus feminism I
hate to say this you have chosen the
wrong cause that's not about Liberty
it's about repression
you